now 6 13 welcome back
trying to relax it is no easy task these
days as we navigate the pandemic in an
ever complicated world
spas around the world are seeing an
increase in popularity of some
non-traditional treatments to ease
stress in new ways here's wendy gillette
she's got details from phuket thailand
at the fairmont scottsdale princess near
phoenix more guests are singing the
praises of singing bowl sound therapy
we use sound or vibration to really
reach them on a cellular level to
promote healing within their body
the hotel says bookings of the service
are up over 75 percent this year people
are seeking alternative therapies more
non-traditional therapies to help them
to become more relaxed and also play a
role in their well-being and intentional
living at the ritz-carlton millennia
singapore
the masseuse synchronizes her movements
with a live cellist
asia is generally a mecca for unusual
spa treatments here at the banyan tree
veya in phuket thailand the new
weightless therapy is a combination of
flotation massage stretching and
meditational sound post covert
many people are seeking relief from
stress and anxiety and this treatment
has been specifically designed to help
people reach a state of healing
and relaxation
south of the border massages at dreams
natura resorts and spa near cancun can
be booked in front of a giant screen
showcasing scenes from nature
nearby guests at rosewood mayakoba go
into nature before receiving a mayan
blessing and choosing herbs to create a
specialized oil for use in their massage
a deep sinkhole also known as the cenote
is the backdrop for treatments at
palmaya the house of ayah also near
cancun it's a sacred area that the
ancient mayans use
to purify everything
it's integral to the temescal a
traditional mayan healing ceremony
in which guests sweat out impurities and
hopefully shed some of the burdens of
the past to experience a rebirth
wow
okay it looks relaxing yeah i think it
helps you experience a rebirth in a hole
in your wallet i was going to say is it
me or does it in the stories we've done
with wendy about travel she seems to
have expensive tastes i know wendy if
you're ever like in need of somebody to
go with you i'd be happy to carry a
camera she's hopscotching from thailand
to cancun to this
dale
looks great meanwhile we're looking at
hostels
she prefers to call it exotic
okay yes tell the other how expensive
[Laughter]
on my vacation we stayed at a comfort
inn where there was a little quiet area
oh yeah that's nice did you get
chocolate on your pillow
no
but free coffee and muffins in the
morning exactly next to the community
coffee pot and the waffle in the lobby
and the waffle maker
see wendy jill every kind of waffle
maker i'm a fan
of 6 16 here it's tuesday morning uh
what kind of it's vacation like what are
we looking at today for folks that are
in town tropical it is